parler de Zone Interdite régalez-vous
c'est pour vous on le fera pas
toujoursch je suis pas obligé on vous
régale merci allez on va parler de zones
interdite hier soir c'est un numéro
spécial prison pour les femmes dans le
centre pénitentiire de Ran ce numéro a
beaucoup fait réagir on va regarder un
premier extrait dans lequel on découvre
deux femmes qui sont déjà mariées et qui
ont une permission de passer plus de 3
jours toutes les deux dans une UVF unité
de vie familiale regardez déjà marié
Yasmina et harmonie elle vont pouvoir
partager un moment d'intimité elles sont
dans une aile de la prison réservée aux
famillesevoir Mar
elles vont séjourner dans cette unité de
vie familiale mise à la disposition des
détenus et de leur famille harmonie et
Yasmina en oublient presque qu'elles
sont en détention ça c'est unable on est
bien là là oua il fait frais on a une
grille au plafond par contre c'est la
seule chose qui vous rappelle la
détention ouais oui mais c'est c'est pas
couvert c'està dire que il y a la grille
mais on a accès à l'air libre mais voilà
c'est les grosses pe c'est grosses pees
oui moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un
travail remarquable alors je sais que
certains trouvent que c'est déplacé
parce que ça fait ou club maide ou
qu'elles ont des moment de liberté mais
moi j'ai pas trouvé ça et je trouve que
avoir un visage découvert comme ça ces
cinq femmes condamnées parfois à de très
longues peines qui témoignent de leurs
moments difficiles de leur dépression de
leur doutes de leur couple c'est
extrêmement émouvant voilà et non la
prison c'est pas un camp de vacances
parce que il y a des moments extrêmement
durs et elles en témoignent ouais alors
pour certaines occasions comme la fête
desm euh par exemple les détenus ont
l'autorisation de faire venir leurs
enfants pour passer un moment privilégié
avec eux
regardez mon bébé
[Musique]
âgé de 17 ans son fils ne conserve que
des bribes de souvenirs de son enfance
avec sa mère j'aimais bien la vie qu'on
avait avant ça se s jamais comme avant
ven me chercher devant l'école avec un
mil000 feuillees ça Meque ah je vais me
rattraper quand je sors ah je dois
partir ouais bon ben
mon sur les 16 parents présents ce
jour-là Yasmina est la seule maman et
pour cause en prison plus de la moitié
des mères n'ont plus de contact avec
leurs
enfants alors qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de ça aussi parce qu'il y a pas
mal de gens qui ont réagi aussi
là-dessus oui il y a pas mal de gens qui
ont réagi en disant limite et je les
cite he qu'ils avaient une meilleure vie
dans cette prison que eux dans la vraie
vie mais c'est ce qu'on dit les gens les
gens on dit par exemple on a vu
quelqu'un qui s'est marié en prison la
personne a dit voilà moi je suis même
pas marié je trouve pas l'amour et on
propose à ces personnes de trouver
l'amour je peux comprendre quand on voit
les extraits pourquoi parce que le rôle
de la prison certes c'est d'assurer la
réinsertion donc évidemment il faut
qu'il y a des moments comme cela mais
c'est aussi de dissuader de retourner en
prison et pardon les personnes qui ont
pris des peines très très lourdes pour a
priori des choses très très graves on
peut se poser la question est-ce que
c'est légitime ou pas de leur offrir
autant de moments de détente je peux
autant de moment de détente pardon mais
l'incarcération c'est la privation de
liberté point c'est pas la privation de
vie sociale c'est pas en faire des
animaux enfermés dans des cages qui
ensuite quand parce qu'elles vont toutes
sortir à un moment ou un autre a qui
quand elles sortent n'ont aucun avenir
aucun but de Ré son famille est pour se
marier en quoi en quoi ça ça gêne le le
fait que cette cette femme en
l'occurrence
elle est en train de purger une peine
qui est la privation de sa liberté elle
ne peut pas
sortir ces faits et gestes sont
contrôlés elle dort quand on lui dit
elle se réveille quand on lui dit elle
va au toil le problème c'est que dans
tous les cas votre débat il est faussé
parce qu'en fait là malheureusement ça
va être du cas par cas si la dame elle a
violé un
a tu une personne on peut pas lui
accorder la même choseune d qui
fait est-ce que tu donnes pas une deè
chance à quelqu'un et malgré tout ce que
tu peux faire dans la vie s'ppelle la
rédemption et moi je trouve que je TR
j'ai trouvé ce magazine absolument
formidable parce que le fait qu'elle
témoigne à visage caché donne beaucoup
d'humanité et donc on peut vraiment les
comprendre et être avec elles et en même
temps je je je je pense que la société
elle doit se préparer à donner une
deuxième chance à même à des très
longues peines donc moi ça moi ça m'a
pas choqué je trouvais ça très bien
alors il y a d'autres extrs vous en avez
parlé il y a un instant Patrick
euh Sandrine on a découvert Sandrine une
détenue qui va pouvoir se marier avec
son compagnon dans la prison regarde
regarde patri ça fait maintenant plus de
2 ans que le couple vit au rythme de la
prison Sandrine à l'intérieur et Antonio
qui l'attend à
l'extérieur et ce jour exceptionnel ils
vont devoir le célébrer derrière les
barreaux monsieur
an consentez à prendre P madame srine
Suzan oui je le
[Musique]
veux prendre pour époux monsieur Antonio
oui je le veux au nom de la loi nous
déclarons uni par le
mariages B merci monour
[Musique]
oui Patricia moi j'ai j'é Patricia très
a été très émue par par cette donne
interdite j'ai trouvé ça moi j'ai été
bouleversée par ces femmes j'ai trouvé
ça incroyable elles disent toutes malgré
le mariage malgré le sexe malgré les
enfants malgré le maquillage et tout ça
qu'elles sont toutes broyées par la
prison et c'est c'est normal et c'est
légi d'être broyé par par la prison mais
malgré tout moi j'oublie pas ce que dit
Pierre buton quand il vient ici il y a
60 % des femmes qui récidivent dans les
5 ans quand elle sortent ben ça il il
faut se poser la question et je pense
qu'il faut leur apporter aussi une
capacité à à se réinsérer dans la
société parce que Sin perion se Maré
Sandrine avoue être en dépression
notamment qu elle serait harcelée par
d'autres détenus regardez il y a deux
sortes de maltraitance il y a la
maltraitance physique celle que j'ai
subi et j'ai subi de la maltraitance
mentale celle que je suis en train de
vivre alors sandrine a pris une décision
radicale être placée à l'isolement
depuis une semaine elle est donc
enfermée toute la journée dans cette
cellule j'ai préféré parer à ma sécurité
que que de qu'on dise à mon mari bah
votre femme elle s'est fait tuer par des
côtes détenus je me bat pour lui euh VO
oui on voit bah on voit très bien que
évidment pas le CL je déf quiconque de
passer une seule journée en prison et de
dire que c'était le Club Med voilà je
dis pas que les fait commis ne méritent
pas une une peine d'emprisonnement je
dis que c'est que c'est la la privation
de liberté et que en dehors de ça
qu'est-ce qu'on veut de la prison on
veut que d'abord elle sanctionne c'est
le cas privation de liberté et on veut
ensuite que elle réinsère donc pour
réinsérer il faut
permettre disu d' retourner aussi Mme
all prison pr prison je comends pourquoi
ce qui sort récidive C'est ça la vraie
question traiter de mieux en mieux et
les faire se marier prendre des cafés
sur une terrasse c'est une solution a
une dame qui interview qui effectivement
cherche des boulots quand ils sortent et
effectivement ça marche beaucoup mieux
quand mariage ils sont deux il y a une
autre personne à côté il a un B sur son
costume c'est pas non plus ouais mais
c'est pas un vrai mariage Guillaume
c'est plus pour faire du bien pour
donner un peu de chur au cœur c'est pas
un mariage ça c'est il s'aime et
d'ailleurs dans dans le reportage on
voit bien à un moment donné ils disent à
une détenue tu vas sortir bientôt dit
j'ai pas envie de sortir parce qu'il y a
mon compagnon à l'intérieur et je l'aime
et je veux rester avec ma compagne c'est
quand même ouf ça veut dire vraiment que
s passe quelque chose tu peux pas n
regard le mariage au ÉtatsUnis où il y a
des peines de 250 ans bah les gens ils
sont tout ils sont encore plus violents
que chez nous donc pas aès on voit aussi
que permettre des espaces de liberté
comme ça c'est acheter la paix sociale à
l'intérieur de la prison d'Ur d'ailleurs
c'est formalisé par les surveillants ils
sont oui ils sont obligés de lâcher du
l'est sinon c'est impossible même pas
lâcher du c'est un peu humain c'est être
un peu humain si tu veux te marier que
tu as pris 6 ans que tu veux te ça va
changer quoi oui oui mais ça va rien
changer qui se marie là c'est pour moi
c'est même pas un vrai mariage pour moi
on te fait plaisir oui mais la question
que te pose Kelly c'est est-ce que tu as
envie d'être humain avec une femme qui a
pris 20 ans parce qu'elle a tué
quelqu'un quo qu'il arrive quoi qu'il
arrive la socié à ce momentl on est dans
un autre débat et on est dans le débat
que moi je mets sur la table à chaque
fois est-ce que vous êtes humain de
laisser quelqu'un 30 ans en prison vous
estce que vous êtes humains les gens à
dire il va aller 30 ans en prison on va
nourir pendant 30 ans en prison est-ce
que vous êtes humain pour faire ça moi
je trouve que c'est pas humain de faire
ça on nenferme pas quelqu'un 30 ans en
prison
solution a peutêre d'autes solution
quelqu'un qui a fait quelque
chose criminalité des gens qui s'amusent
à violer des enfants quand vous vous
êtes content de les voir 30 ans en
prison moi je suis pas content de les
voir
jeen prison c'est peut-être moi je suis
peutêtre plus humain que vous quelqu'un
qui a violé des enfants pour moi il a
pas il
a non je me contred pas quelquun qui
fait 5 ans de prison parce qu'il a pas
un bragage un braquage ou qu'il a volé
quelque chose qui reste 5 6 ans en
prison 8 ans en prison ça me dérange pas
il peut rester 8 ans prison ça va pas
m'embêter de de marier parce qu'il va
ressortir dans 5 ans mais quelqu'un qui
a fait un truc une dinguerie avec
récidive vous voulez le voir 30 ans en
prison moi je veux pas le voir 30 ans en
prison au bout de ta pensé tu
veuxire B ah
d'accord d'accord donc tu es pas plus
humain que nous alors je suis pas plus
humain que vous il y en a qui veulent
les voir 30 ans prison moi il
m'intéresse pas 30 ans prison je vais
pas nourrir un mec 30 ans en prison pour
pour ce dél là m'intéresse pas numé
inter
[Musique]
je perdu es éliminé tu sorti de la vie
tout seul non non là ça s'appelle la
perpétuité ou ou c'est pour ça que je te
dis que je suis contre cette perpétu là
c'est pas 30 ans c'est la perpétuité
pour on va on va dans ce numéro aussi on
apprend comment fonctionne le système du
yoyo regardez vous appellerez les deux
lorsqu'elles sont enfermées en fin de
journée les détenus n'ont pas le droit
de communiquer entre ell mais Yasmina
comme beaucoup d'autres utilise ce qu'on
appelle le yoyo pour contourner cette
interdiction je suis prête bah dis-moi
qu' c'est
bon ce système bien rodé est utilisé
dans toutes les
prisons Yasmina peut ainsi échanger
toutes sortes d'objets avec sa compagne
harmonie tire OK et là le tire c'est bon
attends
waouh c'est bon j'ai reçu ah c'est pas
les vacances voilà c'est pas les
vacances non tellement content de
recevoir un paquet d' M&M c'est pas les
vacances non surtout quand on sait qu'en
fait les gros dealers en prison ont leur
portable et continuent à dealer pour
dehors donc les gens qui qui disent que
c'est le club et qui sont choqués d'un
mariage excusez-moi en prison où toi
mais non mais c'est on le sait
excusez-mo donc ça je suis désolé mais
voir le mariage de quelqu'un en prison
ne m'a pas choqué quand on sait ce qui
se passe tu viens d'ù là tu reviens
SP ve qui veux uneassiette de la
[Rires]
merde ouais bah ouais surtout chez
toi